The Joe Rogan Experience we were talking
about the deviated septum and um it's
weird that
for you a deviated symptom meant one
thing but like for me to be a deception
means I've got like the whole that's a
perforated September for there you go
you're exactly right I think that's
different that's correct I think that's
when people rot out the inside of their
nose from doing blow yeah I did that
yeah I think it already Lang did that
too when I was in rehab uh Knoxville
came and uh visited me and um we took
the shoelace out of Knoxville's Chuck
Taylor and I put it up one nostril
through the [ __ ] hole and just
straight threaded my nose
how big was that hole enough to get the
sheer lace did you get it fixed did that
show it up or still a hole in there
still a hole so you could do that
shoelace trick right now uh it's it I've
tried it but uh yeah I could I could do
it man
you don't need to do that what is that
oh flashlight goes through one hole oh
my God yeah oh wow so that hole is you
could put the flashlight in one nostril
and it shines through the other holy
[ __ ] man yeah the uh
bring up the shoelace I'm sure that's on
there yuck yuck yeah what's you know
getting punched in this thing it's like
God this thing's so delicate your nose
is such oh my God a little instrument
there the [ __ ] um
like that on on my second hour I had uh
that's that's actually in the you're
putting it through oh Jesus
through the hole so the coke just burned
a hole through the center of your
nostril
yeah oh God that's so awful that's
Knoxville
so that that was before I had ever
that was before I had ever broken my
nose right
um really yeah all the [ __ ] you did you
never broke your nose I I never the
first time I broke my nose was when we
were filming Jackass 3D right and and in
that movie like a bam had this trick
he'd sneak up behind you and with with
one hand he would throw a cup of water
in your face and with the other hand he
would like punch you with that
what a great trick
it was called it was called The Rock
he's a regular David Blaine
it was called the Rocky and and uh the
purpose of it was to punch you right
well it was it was to uh take advantage
of what at the time was like super new
technology with the phantom camera
shooting like 1500 frames per second oh
you know it was like uh we were like the
I think the first movie to to really
really take advantage of that and so
like you would see in that super slow
motion like the water and you'd see the
face jiggling you know like it was
pretty rad and they actually like played
the Rocky music but you know
um well so bam yeah there you go
foreign
it doesn't even look like that big of a
deal now but what are you talking about
it looks like brain damage ah that looks
terrible that looks like someone can get
knocked unconscious
oh my God that's such a cheap shot yeah
for sure it's just straight sucker
punching it's totally sucker punching
yeah Jesus you guys did some ridiculous
[ __ ] to each other right and um someone
bam did that to me he broke my nose wow
yeah shocker and I was uh like I didn't
do anything about it for like for like
two months and I just kind of like was
doing about it and then finally like I
didn't like the way it looked and I was
like you know what I'm gonna go get my
[ __ ] nose fixed and I'm gonna make
the [ __ ] movie pay for it so I go to
this like fancy uh like Beverly Hills
nose doctor and he says yeah you know I
I can fix it but it's been two months
you know it's healed this way so now at
this point after we break it oh yeah
yeah Twisted yeah so now like uh if
um we gotta re-break it and I heard that
and I'm like oh no no big deal you know
like I'll live with it then I go to the
[ __ ] Charlie Sheen roast I talked to
Mike Tyson into holding out his fist
just letting me run into it no I was
trying to get myself a black eye and
what happened was I just landed with my
nose on Mike Tyson's Fist and [ __ ]
super broke it and and then that was the
last thing that happened on stage at the
Charlie Sheen roast so now everybody's
like I'm I'm like just mangled my
[ __ ] nose was so broken but the
show's over this guy comes up
so you threw yourself
oh my god dude that's horrific yeah and
then so this guy comes out of the
audience he comes out to me and he says
dude Stevo your nose needs to be set
right now and like that made perfect
sense to me because of what the the
doctor had told me yeah so this the guy
says I'm a Kung Fu like I'm a Kung Fu
instructor like I got you
and I'm like and I'm thinking that
doesn't sound great but like you know
like
it's he's not gonna make it look any
worse I've got very little to lose in
this situation so I sit down on the
stage and he just [ __ ] wrenches my
nose into uh position and and could go
back to that so that's how he fixed it
oh so he didn't go to a doctor I got a
Mike Tyson nose job dude
it looks great yeah looks great dude
come back up to where I started before
that yeah I was definitely Twisted to
the side yeah so once he snapped it then
you pushed it back into place